[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle mastercl organisée
par l'école 3ies et donc aujourd'hui
nous avons un thème qui va être focalisé
sur l'imaginaire c'est-à-dire
l'imaginaire au cinéma ce qui n'est pas
quelque chose de si évident que ça parce
que en France on vous apprend pas que
c'est un pays qui n'est pas toujours
très ouvert à la représentation du
cinémajor et de l'imaginaire et donc
pour parler de ce sujet nous avons le
plaisir d'inviter Thierry poireau
bonjour qui a une carrière qui est
consacrée en tout cas vraiment très
marqué par ce cinéma de l'imaginaire
alors pour nos étudiants peut-être qui
te connaissent pas est-ce que tu peux te
présenter en quelques mots s'il te plaît
en quelques mots alors je Thierry
poireau donc je suis un jeune
réalisateur euh non un peu plus vieux
quand même euh j'ai commencé faer par
publicité courtmétrage publicité j'ai
fais un long métrage un autre long
métrage par la suite et je me suis mis à
faire de la série dans toutes les étapes
de ta carrière tu tu as quand même
représenté beaucoup des univers qui
n'existent pas des univers de genre des
univers liés à la bande dessinée c'est
quasiment systématique oui bah c'est
qu'on est parti d'abord je me présente
moi je travaille aussi avec mon frère à
l'origine qui je m'entends toujours très
bien évidemment qui s'appelle Didier
donc on était connu sous le nom des
frères poireau au débat ça invente pas
euh donc on a commencé et on venait
vraiment l'un comme l'autre on vient
plutôt du milieu de l'art des Beaux Arts
de la BDD il faisait beaucoup de BD moi
de la photo donc on était vraiment
intéressé vraiment au comics à la BD au
milieu de l'art donc on a commencé tout
d'abord par ce biais là en fait ce qui
nous a amené petit à petit au cinéma on
a commencé beaucoup par des films
d'animation donc du stop motion film
d'animation image par image qui était le
plus facile parce qu'on pouvait avir on
avait un super 8 on faisait nos petits
films et on a commencé vraiment à faire
des films et même même des des petites
des du radiographiqu enfin des
radiophoniques donc on faisait aussi des
films que par cassette juste le son
qu'on avait pas assez d'argent et ça
commencé vraiment comme ça en fait
jusqu'à ben je te laisserai finir mais
jusqu'à l'arrivée des escarpins qui est
mon premier courtmétrage oui la
transition est toute faite c'est-à-dire
que le premier courtmétrage donc c'est
un un film qui s'appelle les escarpins
sauvages que vous avez coréalisé avec
Didier en
1994 je vais résumer rapidement
l'histoire c'est donc on est dans un
univers qui est très particulier avec un
noir et ass expressionniste on suit donc
un météorologiste qui est dans un
univers comme ça dans une forêt un peu
sombre et qui va rencontrer des
créatures de bois qui s'animent et qui
vont être hostiles à son encontre bien
évidemment on voit tout de suite qu'il y
a une pâte très forte il y a une
proposition très forte à l'intérieur
mais comment il a été fait c'est-à-dire
est-ce que il a été fait en en en groupe
d'artistes comme ça de manière
artisanale est-ce qu'il y avait une
production derrière comment ça s'est
lancé c'est un courmétrage qui a été
fait faut le savoir dans le jardin de
nos parents en fait tout tous les trucs
en bois c'est dans une c'est ni plus ni
moins que le jardin de nos parents qui
était des à côté des agriculteurs voilà
donc tout a été fait sur place avec une
prode parisienne qui était des gens qui
viennent de l'animation qui une toute
petite prode ils sont tous venus habiter
chez mes parents pendant 15 jours et on
l'a fait image par image comme ça on a
vraiment fait vraiment un film bricolé
avec vraiment très peu d'argent que la
bande son a coûté deux fois plus cher
que le film et ça a été fait comme ça
c'est vraiment une collaboration d'abord
artistique fait de de photos d'images on
a inventé l'univers petit à petit ça mis
du temps j'avis beaucoup d'amis des
beauzards qui venaient faire les décors
l'été avec moi on a fabriqué vous verrez
dans le a le film il a un grand château
qu'on a fabriqué dans le fond du jardin
voà c'est vraiment un travail d'équipe
d'amis comme beaucoup de cormétrages se
font en fait voilà l'origine et quel a
été le retentissement du film par que il
a été primé au Festival International de
Paris he du Film Fantastique de Paris et
et quel a été les retombées pour vous
bah nous c'est une carrière un petit peu
parce que le film est quand même un peu
spécial comme on peut voir surtout
queand on c'est un peu vieilli pour le
jeune public c'est un film un peu
étrange qui à l'époque se ça se faisait
absolument pas du tout euh du coup ça a
bien marché moins à Paris oui à Paris ça
a bien marché c'est vrai qu'à
l'international on était à New York ça
été primimé un peu on a fait un grand
tour euh comme ça pour un premier
courmétrage n on était assez content
c'est la première fois qu'on voyageait
même et euh du coup après le film on
s'est fait découvrir par d'autres prodes
en fait c'est c'est là qui a commencé
l'autre partie de ma ma carrière donc
coup le de publicité où ils ont
découverrt le savoir faire de
l'animation ça leur plaisait en fait
donc ça vous a exposé si je résume et ça
vous a fait découvrir et derrière un
autre milieu donc le milieu de la
publicité bah vous a accueilli d'une
certaine manière vous avez travaillé sur
des spots quand même de grande ampleur
avec des effets spéciaux de pointe pour
l'époque et cetera comment on passe de
ces deux univers là bah en fait c'est
souvent il y a les même je je parle pour
pour les étudiants qui sont là mais
enfit c'est pour les mêmes on commence
toujours par l'imaginaire enfin il y a
il y a que ça soit so en publicité en
cinéma même maintenant les ceux qui qui
qui qui cartonnent en pub moi j'en fais
encore de la pub donc je vois ce qui se
passe en publicité qui sont des des des
jeunes je sais pas si vous connaissez
les Mégaforce qu'on fait beaucoup de de
de pub en ce moment ils viennent pareil
moi je les ai connu quand ils étaent
plus jeune quand nous on était déjà plus
haut il ils avaient commencer vraiment
c'était du bricolage en fait c'était du
bricolage chez eux il fa ça commence
souvent un peu de la même chose c'est
vraiment par une passion de faire avant
tout c'est pas au-delà de l'apprendre
c'est de faire les choses en fait c'est
je pense que c'est c'est c'est cette
passion de faire qui fait que les gens
viennent te voir aussi te voir et après
il y a l'univers qui est à l'intérieur
après il faut tomber sur un producteur
ou des gens qui qui arrivent à voir
aussi à travers l'univers parce qu'
évidemment ce qui est un peu plus
compliqué en ce moment c'est que les
gens ils veulent tout de suite voir dire
qu'ils veulent voir un courtmétrage et
pour voir ce qu'ils peuvent en faire en
publicité ou en autre chose là il y
avait des gens un peu plus visionnaires
c'est qu'ils arrivaient à déceler à
l'intérieur de l'univers un talent on va
pouvoir en faire ça on va pouvoir faire
quelque chose ce qui encore le cas je je
rassure tout le monde mais mais c'est
vraiment ça met du temps mais après je
peux pas dire le mécanisme exact par je
pense que chacun a sa propre mécanique
nous on a été aidé à l'époque on a eu
des parins il y a eu Yan Kunen qui était
un quelqu'un qui qui qui a fait des des
longmétrages et par la suite qui avait
tombé sur notre courtmétrage qui aimait
beaucoup donc qui nous avait aidé un
petit peu aussi c'est un milieu en fait
il y a le milieu de c'est le milieu de
l'animation c'est vraiment le milieu de
l'animation parce que lui aussi
s'intéresse à l'animation et qui c'est
souvent un parrain qui t'aide j'ai un
Parin c'est lui était un peu plus âgé
était plus en avant que nous et nous a
fait monter des marches en fait si on on
on liste très rapidement parce que vous
avez fait énormément de de spot de pub
mais vous avez fait une pub avec Marie
José Perrec pour une marque de
chaussures qui a été un phénomène enfin
c'était très très important à l'époque
vous avez fait une campagne de pub
également pour une marque de soda
version rouge donc version film
d'horreur euh qui était tellement connu
que même dans les cours d'école le
slogan final était rejoué de à tous les
âges et puis peut-être on voit sur ce
bord de la publicité donc pour une
marque de chewingum avec avec une statue
de la Liberté qui se désabeille et qui
plonge dans AB BA de Manathan cette
publicité enfin c'est peut-être la
publicité de cette décennie quand même
c'est c'est je crois que vous avez été
quand même
fortement comment dire primé pour cette
pour cette pub oui bah ça c'est la
publicité qui nous a fait un peu
commencer ça nous qui nous a lancé en
fait hein on avait fait des moi j'étais
assez jeune en fait même parce que j'ai
commencé à la sortie des beauards en
fait j'ai pas fait je suis parti
directement des bzards en à faire des
pubs de 3 ans après donc j'avais à peine
26 ans 25 ans 26 ans mais c'est c'est un
peu la pub qui nous a lancé donc il nous
c'est aussi c'est pas une enfin sans
doute un peu de chance hein parce que ça
fait les milieux de la publicité il faut
trouver les bon concept l'animation
après on se retrouve avec un budget nous
énorme à gérer al qu'on était pas du
tout habitué en fait les trucages que ça
soit après le les trucages par exemple
que ça soit la 3D ou quoi que ce soit
que la 3D ça sprend c'est comme de
l'animation enfin moi qui me des
beauzards les j'aime beaucoup le
évidamment la post-production mais la 3D
ça ressemble beaucoup à l'animation
c'est le mêmes sujets on retrouve
retrouve les clés d'animation on
retrouve la lumière on retrouve c'est
des choses que déjà quand on a travaillé
plastiquement sur l'animation l'image
par image le stop motion c'est assez
c'est l'affiliation est assez rapide en
fait donc ça on arrive assez rapidement
à s'y retrouver et à maîtriser en fait
le sujet mais c'est vrai que pour
l'époque en je vois les images aussi
c'était parce que la 3D marchait pas
comme comme maintenant c'est qu'on
mettait une semaine à calculer les
quelques images on a mis longtemps c'est
4 mois 5 mois pour faire une publicité
là c'est n plus le cas maintenant en
fait mais et surtout un tour à New York
nous on était tout jeune dans les rues
de New York assez dingue on va aller à
la prochaine marche de ta carrière donc
là c'est l'entrée dans le cinéma avec
ton premier long-métrage donc coréalisé
aussi avec Didier avec ton frère qui
s'appelle atomic Circus le retour de
James
batille c'est voilà c'est une
comédie fantastique de SF je pense qu'on
peut en terme de genre on peut déjà
réunir ces trois éléments là je vais
essayer de résumer l'histoire alors déjà
ce que l'on peut voir c'est le casting
de ha volol on a Vanessa Paradis on a
benoî poulvord on a Jason Fleming cet
acteur anglais qui qui est dans au
casting et Jean-Pierre Mariel qui
remplace au piedlevé jean-yann qui est
décédé juste avant le début du tournage
c'est vraiment un univers de bande
dessiné donc c'est dans une toute petite
ville où Vanessa Paradis joue le rôle de
conchia qui est une chanteuse assez
populaire dans ce petit village et elle
va devoir faire face à deux invasions
donc l'vasion de l'industrie musicale
par le biais de B pouvord qui joue le
rôle d'un impressario absolument
infernal et une invasion de poupe
extraterrestre qui viennent d'on saisou
comment c'est possible qu'un film comme
ça existe en France donc est-ce que ça a
été une opportunité facile donc un
indice la réponse est non comment vous
avez réussi à monter un film pareil la
la pub ça cartonnait en pub donc on
s'est dit on avait envie de faire n nos
premiers longmétrages on avait plusieurs
projets en cours des plus sérieux des
plus drôles et c'est celui qui est
arrivé sur le le haut du panier où c'est
une comédie c'est une comédie horrifique
assez drôle à la même époque il y avait
presque Men in Black comme ça donc ça
leur parlait c'est que les producteurs
français c'est improbable mais ça
parlait mais à l'origine c'était un film
à petit budget en fait c'était nous on
est vraiment des petit budget de film
d'horreur un peu ind on était beaucoup
plus intéressé par par ce genre de film
et le fait est que on connaissait PV il
travaillait avec notre pro donc c'est
Benoît qui était un ami avec qu'on
connaissait en fait dans le milieu parce
qu'il traîit au milieu des des mêmes
personnes avec nous Séta intéressé au
projet on lui avait proposé un rôle il
dit ah d'accord je vais le faire et une
fois que Bono avait dit oui qui était
très populaire à l'époque d'un coup bah
les chaînes ont commencé à s'y
intéresser et à remettre un peu plus
d'argent donc oui mais c'est bien mais
il faudrait que du coup le conteia soit
une fille connue donc on a refait le
tour et après il y a Vanessa qui est
arrivé du coup en Vanessa alors qu'elle
faisait très peu de cinéma à l'époque é
Los Angeles a accepté et ça s'est envolé
en fait le budget s'est envolé tout s
envolé donc le film a pris une
proportion énorme et d'un petit film ind
petit budget on est passé un énorme film
avec une attente sauf que tout le monde
s'en ballait parce que c'était faut
savoir que dans le cinéma beaucoup de
gens c'est le castingfin à l'époque
passait presque avant l'histoire ça le
casting drôle tout ils avaient même pas
presque pas vu l'histoire donc on s'est
retrouvé à faire le film mais c'était la
même histoire en fait que notre petit
film ind qui était un film débile
pratiquement série Z donc on s'est
retouvé avec cet objet atypique au final
avec des des distributeurs qui ont
découvert le film en disant mais c'est
un film ind series avec des stars oui
c'est ce qu'on avait vendu mais ils
l'ont presque découvert par la suite ce
n donc en fait c'est qu'il y a des ce
film on a réussi à le faire pas parce
que des gens savaient exactement ce
qu'ils faisaient mais qu'ils étaient
presque aveuglés par le par le par le
casting ils nous ont laissé faire ce
qu'on avait envie nous on était très
jeune donc je je n'arrivais pas à voir
moi ni moi ni Didier sur ce qu'elle nous
retomberé dessus en fait c'est que
d'avoir pris un film aussi j'isait
débile avec beaucoup de d'amour he c'est
des films que j'aimais beaucoup de séri
B que j'aime beaucoup mais on l'a fait
avec un budget beaucoup trop gros donc
ça nous est revenu dessus en disant ah
là là c'est des gens de la publicité qui
sont habités avoir des gros budgets ils
ont fait n'importe quoi mais à l'origine
nous notre film était peu c un petit
budget en fait donc c'est quelque chose
qui s'est fait comme ça pas par hasard
he mais il y a eu des a des des des un
contexte un peu étrange où les gens se
sont emballés sur un sujet plutôt de
bien regarder ce qu'il faisait comme
projet en fait le film est bardé
d'effets spéciaux c'est-à-dire il y a
des effets spéciaux physiques a des
effets spéciaux 3D aussi estce qui à
l'époque était pas si courant que 100 et
particulièrement pour un film français
il faut toujours le souligner comment
vous avez travaillé C cet aspect là
est-ce que c'éit un film qui était
extrêmement préparé storyboardé complexe
à à gérer avec aussi un casting de haut
niveau c'est-à-dire il y a il y a quand
même beaucoup de choses à à mener de
front j'ai l'impression c'était euh je
pourrais mentir enant que c'était ultra
préparé c'était bien préparé parce qu'on
faisait beaucoup de dessins mais ça un
joyeux même il y a des interviews de
Benoît qui disent c'est un son film à
peu près le plus bordélique cé un joyeux
joyeux bordel c'est très rock and roll
euh mais non c'était storybardé pour
tout ce qui était technique on savait où
on allait qu'on avait fait beaucoup en
pub donc on avait fait les storyboards
de tous les de toutes les scènes euh je
pour le reste c'est un tout petit peu
plus on s'était laissé un petit peu
aller aussi c'était un petit peu plus
improvisé par moment en fait maisce
qu'il y avait un esprit très rock and
roll aussi à l'intérieur qu'on voulait
garder ça a été préparé évidemment en
amont tout ce qui éit trucage mais ça
l'expérience qu'on avait de la publicité
nous a a beaucoup aidé aussi hein c'est
que la publicité ça aide aussi pour le
coup moi ça m'avait aidé à à me sentir
très à l'aise avec les effets spéciaux
c'est quelque chose que je connais très
bien donc c'était pas vraiment un
problème on était avec des gens avec qui
ont travaillait beaucoup qui était buff
compagnie à l'époque qui qui av fait
beaucoup d'autres films que j'avais
rencontré en publicité donc c'est des
gens avec qui déjà je travaillais
beaucoup quand on faisait la quand on a
commencé à faire le film je continue à
travailler là même dans les les
prochaines séries là la nouvelle sur les
même personne en fait et donc si je
résume vraiment le passage à la pub ça a
été aussi quelque part un marqueur un
entraînement total en fait pour arriver
au au monde de la fiction donc est-ce
que ça veut dire que ces univers sont
pas si différents ça ils sont très alors
c'est très dur en France ce que j'ai
appris par la suite c'est très dur de
passer de la publicité au cinéma parce
que on est toujours étiqueté publicité
c'est on est étiqueté à des gens qui
font que de l'esthétisme qui savent pas
raconter une histoire qui ont beaucoup
d'argent qui sont bourgeois mais qui
savent rien à faire un film alors que
nous on venait vraiment du courtmétrage
en fait hein mais mais tu mets du temps
ça c'est quelque chose qu'on met du
temps donc on notamment que le film
avait été critiquer parce que le
scénario était ce qu'il était mais
c'était une série B qu'on assumait tel
quel euh donc du il y a peu de gens qui
arrivent à passer de la pub en France
peu de gens à faire de la pub au cinéma
c'est assez compliqué c'est pas du tout
la même chose aux États-Unis ou ou dans
d'autres en Angleterre en Espagne ù
c'est beaucoup plus perméable il y a des
des grands réalisateurs américains David
Fincher comme ça c'est vraiment des des
mecs de la publicité en fait qu'on euh
en France on VI on vient beaucoup plus
du du cinéma c'est vrai que c'est mieux
de commencer par des
courtmétrages continuer que ce soit des
différentes écoles j'ilà de la fam en
passant par d'autres et c'est très bien
c'est que c'est ça ça ça couche de très
bons films c'est que de passer par la
publicité et de revenir après au long
métrage c'est un peu long c'est un peu
dur parce qu'on est étiqueté qu'on a pas
confiance que même les techniciens qui
travaillent en publicité notamment les
chefs opérateurs ont le même problème
c'est qu' alors qu'il y en a des très
très très bons on leur dit toujours non
c'est de la publicité c'est pas pareil
que le cinéma alors que pour moi c'est
la même enfin voilà on fait des images
on crée des en plus on crée des petites
histoires l'inverse par exle se passe
très bien beaucoup de de de gens métrage
font des
pubs il y a pas de problème ça se voit
pas la différence mais ça repose aucun
problème c'est l'inverse qui est
toujours plus compliqué en fait j'ai
l'impression enentendant qu' a il y a
comme en France une suspicion
d'esthétiste c'està direire que si on
fait des des des images ou du visuel et
ça peut être douteux par par rapport à
sa capacité à raconter tout simplement
une histoire si je résume j'ai
l'impression que c'est ça ben c'estd que
dans le je dirais pas que enfin c'est
dur de dire en France que je suis
français puis je
continueta dir après j'étais aux
États-Unis puis je suis très content de
revenir en France honnêtement
mais c'est vrai que le au-delà de
l'esthétisme c'est se tabler sur le
visuel c'est avec des gens qui
travaillent beaucoup sur le visuel sur
le l'art visuel en fait même de
l'abstraction des univers qu'on appelle
plus BD ou quoi que ce soit ça passe
très c'est très difficile de le faire
acceptter en France parce qu'on est dans
une culture qui est basée plus sur pas
plus littéraire mais plus réalisme et
mais même le public a du mal que moi je
me frude au public maintenant avec mes
différentes séries tout ça ça marche
toujours moins bien dit qu'il y a du
fantastique que quand il y en a pas en
fait parce que c'est on n'est pas un
public français sur lesquel ça marche
énormément ça marche bien en Angleterre
en Espagne ils font des grands films
fantastiques dans leur culture en fait
on on va revenir à Tomic Circus pour
parler de la réception du film euh donc
le film sort c'est un ovni au sens
propre h comment il a été perçu bon tu
nous as donné des des indices quand les
distributeurs l'ont découvert ils
étaient pas forcément préparés à au
résultats donc comment ça s'est passé
pour vous ça a été un petit peu dur à la
sortie et c'est par la suite en fait
c'est vraiment un film qui nous qui qui
s'est nourri par la suite qui qui m'a
beaucoup plus aidé mais un an après VO
là ça c'est revenu beaucoup plus
facilement comme beaucoup de films ça
remarche en DVD ça a marchait plutôt ça
il était extrêmement enfin même piraté
un peu partout euh d'ailleurs maintenant
on peut le revoir plus plus facilement
sur Youtube que sur que sur autre choses
euh donc c'est c'est vraiment le film
après il a pris il a pris son envol mais
par un autre BIA en fait pas par le BIA
classique donc moi c'est pas un film qui
m'a aidé à rentrer did ni moi dans le
film dans le milieu du cinéma dans le
milieu du cinéma dit merci au revoir
c'est pas pour vous donc j'ai dû
repartir un peu refaire la pub avant de
revenir au cinéma vous êtes resté proche
de Vanessa Paradis parce que vous avez
réalisé le documentaire de son concert
c'est en 2008 si je dis pas de bêtises
et ça a été quelque chose de porteur
parce que ça a débouché quand même sur
une
reconnaissance est-ce que tu peux pe
nous dire comment vous avez travaillé ce
documentaire comment ça s'est fait
est-ce que c'était un accident une
opportunité puis ce que ça a provoqué
chez vous derrière bah nous c'était
vraiment là on était en c'était vraiment
une opportunité c'est vraiment par
amitié au début par par Vanessa qui
devait faire un qui voulait on lui avait
demandé de faire un un film sur sa
tournée elle avait pas du tout envie de
se faire filmer la tournée donc elle
avait dit bah n avait demandé est-ce que
vous avez une idée je voyais un peu les
captation à quoi ça ressemblait mais
s'était pas penché vraiment dessus avec
Didier donc on l'a vraiment fait assez
simplement
mais d'un point de vue plus cinéma en
fait on s'est vraiment amusé à le faire
du cinéma on a fait les interviews à
s'amuser en fait avec eux c'était avec
Vanessa mathieed il y avait tout c'était
son sur sa tournée mais cétait une
opportunité qu'on a pris vraiment que
c'était quelque chose d' part moi ça
j'ai beaucoup appris par rapport au
presque au côté documentaire où je
m'étais pas beaucoup penché sur la
question c'estàd que là on était pas
maître des images qu'on devait juste
simplement filmer les images qu'on et
être là à moment où ça se passait en
fait qu'il y avait des petits voilà
c'est c'est des petits moments de vie
même si on pouvait pas tout filmer parce
qu'à l'époque il y avait même fess sa
vie éta éant privée même si de côté à
l'époque c'était avec Johnny de et il
était cadreur pour nous donc ça c'était
la petite histoire j'avais Johnny de
comme cadreur qui adorait faire la le 16
MIM donc il nous a filmmer il a filmé
avec nous en fait pendant un mois CIT le
côté très agréable de l'expérience et
l'autre côté agréable de l'expérience
c'est que vous avez été primimé au
Victoire de la Musique en 2009 oui oui
bah oui
par oui oui c'était ouii c'était
toujours agréable de recevoir des prix
mais c'était pas enfin nous on a
vraiment fait ça que c entre pas j'ai
pas fait pardessus la gambre on l' fait
vraiment très très bien mais c'est
vraiment voilà on avait pas d'attentere
plus que ça c'était un parcours entre la
publicité on aime bien faire plusieurs
choses différentes à Didier donc c'était
vraiment une façon de de rencontrer les
gens moi j'ai vraiment plus appris sur
le côté documentaire ce que je dis sur
sur sur ce qui m'a servi par la suite en
fait de capter les choses de monter
aussi différemment les films sans être
trop dans le contrôle des images mais
c'est de de capter ce qui se passe un
peu sur un plateau alors là on est en on
va arriver dans les années 2010 euh oui
on progresse assez vite et c'est à ce
moment-là où vous séparez votre binôme
avec ton frère Didier alors vous
continuez de travailler ensemble mais en
tout cas vous ne coréalisez plus donc
comment ça s'est passé c'est deux envies
différentes c'est bah c'était nous déjà
parce qu'on c'est un binôme on est frère
donc c'est c'est assez à la fois
différent et plus facile c'est qu'on ne
se posait pas de questions comme il y a
beaucoup de binômes dans le cinéma mais
c'est c'estez compliqué parce qu'au
moment il y a il y a les egoos qui
travaillent on travaille chacun de notre
côté donc pour ceux qui travaillent
ensemble au début c'est simple puis
après c'est toujours un peu plus
compliqué que ça soit alors dans les
réussites les échecs il faut les Chun
les assume un peu différemment nous on
était frères donc de toute façon on
avait notre mère au milieu si on on
gueulait on était ramené à la maison
c'est venu vraiment un moment parce
qu'on avait beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
passé de temps ensemble à toujours faire
tout ensemble c'est voilà on avait
besoin un petit peu d'air on avait des
des idées un petit peu différentes c'est
qu'on avait deux ce que j'ai fait par la
suite est un petit peu différent de ce
que j'ai fait au départ avec Didier CIT
des envies que Didier partageait pas
viceversa sur le je dirais sur plus sur
le cinéma en fait donc on on a partagé
un petit peu nos nos voix voilà Didi
avait envie aussi de revenir faisait
beaucoup de d'art de sculpture de
peinture de cinéma enfin VO il y a un
truc beaucoup plus artistique là où j'
allais plus dans un cinéma je dirais
plus
traditionnel donc on a nos chemins se
sont un peu séparés on te retrouve au
cinéma en 2014 avec un film qui a
nouveau une comédie mais une comédie de
genre qui s'appelle goal of the dead
alors c'est un film qui est assez
particulier parce que on on est quelque
part un peu dans l'univers d'Atomic
Circus dans le dans on va dire la
philosophie parce que on est sur du
cinéma de genre donc là on est dans le
film de zombies qui est traité aussi de
manière très décalée donc de manière
drôle décalé dans le sens où c'est un
petit peu comme SH of the dead on ramène
un petit peu l'imaginaire américain qui
qui est très codifié dans l'univers
français donc là c'est une équipe de
foot je synthétise c'est une équipe de
foot qui va se faire envahir par des
zombies et là où le film est est quand
même très étonnant et reste une
expérience aussi c'est qu'il est scindé
en deux parties en deux mi-temps donc la
première mi-temps est réalisée par
Benjamin Rocher la deuxième mi-temps
donc est réalisé par tes soins donc
comment tu as été intégré dans ce film
et quel était on va dire le l'idée
derrière cette expérience en deux temps
bah en fait c'est une expérience moi je
suis arrivé par la suite en fait c'est
une expérience qui était Inti par le
producteur donc le frère qui s'appelle
Raphaël rocher qui est le frère de
Benjamin qui est devenu après mon
producteur avec qui j'ai travaillé par
la suite lui c'est c'est des vrais fans
que ça soit les appelle les frères
rochers c'est les frères poireau c'est
les frères rochers très fans de cinéma
de genre donc ils avaient monté une
production et eux ils voulaient ils
étaient depuis quelques années à faire
des films de genre et ils avaient envie
de reprendre comme le Greno ça des films
comme ça des programmes un peu
particulier vraiment sans prétention
qu'on allait passer soit ça allait
sortir au cinéma l'été soit directement
en DVD c'était vraiment le but de avouer
en fait moi qui venais vraiment de ce
cinéma que j'aimais beaucoup le cinéma
cinéma VHS euh ben j'aime aussi les
grands films d'auteur mais j'aime aussi
les films de séries Z et B parce que j'y
trouve un l'artisanat l'art le début du
cinéma en fait qui m'intéresse aussi
beaucoup et je trouve ça assez touchant
donc cétait vraiment venu avec cette
idée moi je me dis bah banco c'était pas
simple parce que cétait réalisé un film
en deux parties je contôla ni la
première donc j'ai attaqué la 2uxè euh
mais je l'ai fait vraiment comme une une
cé c'était pas au début comme une
commande puis après bon on s'est
beaucoup attaché au au projet on s'est
beaucoup amusé moi je l'ai fait vraiment
parce que ça relançait un peu les choses
aussi par que j'avais du mal à revenir
dans le cinéma parce qu'on avait du mal
à faire confiance après faut savoir
qu'après atomic Circus on avait vraiment
étiqueté comme étant des fous du cinéma
c'est incontrôlable le film bargeot
voilà c'est à ne pas approcher à ne pas
donner un scénario surtout pas parce
qu'autrement ça va exploser euh du coup
fallait vraiment que j'arrive gentiment
à dire non mais j'arrive à faire du
cinéma c'estd qu'il y a un film qui
commence à un point qui un point B fait
en temps de jour contre contrôlable donc
j' aussi dans cette idée là en fait et
après ça ça bien ça bien ça bien
redémarré on s'est beaucoup amusé donc
après c'était un programme fait pour
Canal Plus en fait de de binô qui a
sorti un petit peu qui est sorti un peu
en salle mais c'est un programme un peu
atypique en fait mais j'aime bien en
fait c'est des problèmes encore une fois
presque unouveni en fait oui parce que
tu enchaînes tout de suite en 2015 si je
dis pas de bêtises avec un autre film un
autre long métrage qui s'appelle alone
alors c'est la traduction française de
Don grow up donc on on voit l'affiche
c'est un film qui effectivement est est
assez différent par rapport à ce que tu
as fait jusqu'à présent parce que déjà
ce n'est pas une comédie on est toujours
dans du cinéma fantastique alors don
grop en quelques mots ça raconte le le
monde dévasté par une contamination qui
transforme les gens en infectés donc
c'est vrai qu'on on retrouve des des des
codes qu'on a déjà vu un imaginaire qui
est déjà existant sauf que la manière
dont c'est traité est très particulière
parce qu'on est sur un casting
d'adolescents et le film est
exclusivement vu à leur à leur niveau ce
on n'est pas dans quelque chose qui
détourne les les choses au contraire
c'est c'est vraiment on voit ça par la
par leur côté c'est vraiment par la
petite histoire par leur regard et c'est
un film qui est très sensible et qui est
quasiment attimiste comment tu tu es
arrivé dans un changement de ton aussi
aussi différent c'est un film avant tout
poétique le film de genre enfin si je
raconte l'histoire c'est que bon les
infectés peu importe qu'on a déjà vu
beaucoup c'est juste la particularité
c'est que ça ne touche que les adultes
donc en fait ça ne parle juste c'est une
façon c'était mon peterp en fait c'est
de à quel moment tu passes de l'enfance
à l'âge adulte euh c'est se poser la
question c'est quoi ça veut dire quoi
d'être adulte est-ce que tuas un adulte
à 18 ans 20 ans 30 ans ou tu peut être
plus jeune ou plus vieux donc après on a
réfléchi là-dessus avec ma coscénariste
et c'est vraiment un film sur
l'adolescence qui est un sujet qui me
qui me passionne aussi donc j'aime
beauoup j'ai d'autres projets en cours
sur le même sujet euh et c'était plus un
film c'est un film poétique en fait il y
a c'est une histoire d'amour entre deux
adolescents un qui va un qui en passe de
devenir adultes de ceux qui se posent
des questions donc c'était vraiment
cette idée-là et travailler aussi avec
des jeunes comédiens ça ça me j'avais
envie depuis très longtemps c'est un
projet que j'avais depuis longtemps mais
c'était dur à à vendre c'est c'est comme
tout bon projet he souvent il faut faire
ses preuves autre part et après on rêve
à le vendre c'est un projet que j'avais
depuis longtemps après j'ai fait avec un
petit budget du coup j'ai dû couper
quelques quelques P de l'histoire ça
c'est un petit peu mes mes regrets mais
le casting j'en étais très content et ce
qu'on en a fait j'étais assez fier en
fait de voilà c'était vraiment c'est
vraiment des petits budgets c'est permet
de faire des films c'est vous de 2
millions et demi 2 millions fait au
Canaris donc c'est vraiment des films
qu'on vous propose une coproduction
espagnole française tourner avec des
anglais c'est vraiment les films qu'on
faut se battre he faut se battre pour
les faire c'est tourner en à peine un
mois mois et demi alors qu'il y a
beaucoup de scènes beaucoup d'effets
voilà et le le film une fois terminé
est-ce que il a été suffisamment diffusé
est-ce que ça a eu des échos positifs
pour pour toi oui ça après c'est les
filmson appelle c'est vraiment les films
petit budget sorti donc c'est plus il
est sorti en Angleterre en France il est
sorti en en VOD directement il est sorti
en États-Unis en Angleterre donc ça ça
ça m'a amené d'autres choses d'autres
d'AES petits projets mais c'est vraiment
les petits films qui faut se battre pour
voir voilà c'est c'est vraiment les
films d'auteur j'ai des films d'auteur
fantastique à demon on en fait beaucoup
en France il y en a quelquesuns qui
sortent notamment mais qu'on voit peu en
fait parce que c'est pas c'est les la
salle maintenant c'est quand même
compliqué demain on avance là vraiment
dans le moment de ta carrière qui nous
amène quasiment au début des années 2020
on est en 2019 là on progresse à nouveau
parce que là on te retrouve après
elone au générique d'une série cette
fois euh donc c'est encore autre chose
c'est la fiction c'est toujours
l'imaginaire mais dans un autre contexte
donc tu as réalisé donc zone blanche
cette série du service public qui a été
diffusé sur France 2 qui est quand même
une série qui est très très très
étonnante hein parce que on est dans un
univers qui est quasiment mystique euh
comment tu es arrivé à la série télé
après ces expériences de cinéma quand
j'ai fait ça c'est vraiment la bascule
entre le pas la fin du cinéma le cinéma
est encore bien bien là et pour
longtemps mais la série télé c'était pas
juste une série qu'on regardait la télé
il y avait vraiment des ambitions de
cinéma qui arrivaient donc par la les
nouvelles séries qui arrivaient des
États-Unis d'Angleterre HBO de partout
donc le cinéma il commence à piocher
dans le monde du cinéma et d' unee envie
de faire des séries qui soient qu'
appellent très cinéma maintenant ça veut
plus rien dire parce qu'il y a des
séries télé qui sont plus
cinématographiques et il des films qui
sont carrément qui ressemblent à des
séries euh mais c'était vraiment le
début de l'époque donc moi on est venu
me chercher après don grup en fait c'est
vraiment don grup que j'ai j'ai projeté
dans des festivals c'est le producteur
qui a vu don gr et qui a vu dans ce film
un peu cette sensibilité un peu
étrange quelque chose qui lui a parlé
qui m'a proposé du coup de travailler
sur l'adaptation de de zonees Blanche
moi je ne voulais pas trop y aller au
début parce que je me dis voilà c'est
pour une série France 2 c'était pas du
tout ce que je regardais je me
retrouvais à faire jeais déjà finir ma
carrière à faire
des je dirais pas d'autres noms mais
d'autres série je n'ai pas envie de
faire donc j'y étais vraiment d'accord
mais moi je fais du cinéma j'ai envie de
m'amuser c'est du fantastique on m' dit
oui tu peux y aller donc on a proposé
j'avoue qu'il nous une certaine liberté
j'ai découvert a mon producteur qui j'ai
une très ami qui m'a poussé qui a dit
allez on y va on y va on y va on a
proposé ça a plutôt très bien marché ils
ont fait une saison 2 c'est sur Netflix
ça été rché par Netflix donc ça ça nous
a ça c'est c'est un c'est une série je
dirais qui était une commande parce que
ça reste quand même quelque chose j'ai
pas j'ai pas initié j'ai pas écrit qui
est assez agréable qui quand on vient du
long métrage et je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens qui font la série du
long métrage aussi il y a un petit
problème de budget parce qu' faut aller
vite et par rapport au long mais mais le
fait de pouvoir développer des
personnages de rencontrer des gens
d'avoir une famille ça que du théâtre en
fait d'un famille de de de de les
auteurs les les producteurs toutes les
équipes on voyage vraiment ensemble en
fait ça c'est très agréable quand quand
je t'entends il y a il y a quelque chose
qui me marque c'est-à-dire que dans le
domaine du cinéma j'ai l'impression
qu'il faut lutter pour un poser des
films li à l'imaginaire ou du genre et
cetera et là en série on vient de
chercher on on désire quelque part ce
ces univers là on les laisse se déployer
c'est quand même très étonnant que
France Télévision laisse un tel univers
sur son antenne est-ce que ça veut dire
que la série télé est beaucoup plus
ouverte en fait quelque part en fait ça
c'est ça s'explique assez simplement
c'est que le le le cinéma faut faire le
plus grand chiffre le plus populaire
donc on fait on fait un film faut qu'il
attire le plus de gens possible donc en
fait c'est très dur le fantastique étant
quelque chose en France qui est pas très
bien qui ne marche jamais en fait très
peu là où en ce que j'appelle série ou
plateforme plateforme c'est exactement
le contraire c'est il leur faut des
niches une plateforme marche surtout
s'il y a là il y a un secteur une série
qui fait fantastique une série qui fait
amour une série qui fait comédie eu
c'est séparé et comme les gens viennent
bwer ils viennent regarder la série et
il viennent regarder la plateforme ils
ont tout intérêt à faire des des
marqueurs très précis ils veulent du
fantastique soit très fantastique de la
comédie soit très comédie donc après on
retrouve le même problème de mélange de
genre mais par contre eux ils ont pas
peur parce que ça fait partie exactement
une une je dis une plateforme ce soit je
parle de plateforme soit France 2
netflixbo Canal+ pour moi c'est il
marche à peu près tous pareil c'est
qu'ils ont vraiment envie d'avoir des
des des secteurs très précis et des des
marqueurs très précis pour un public qui
peut aller de l'un à l'autre si je
prends une famille bah il y a l' do qui
aime que les films d'horreur la la la
mère qui veut regarder des films d'amour
donc ils ont intérêt à garder simplement
c'est très technique hein d'avoir un
abonnement avec une famille et c'est
plus facile sachant que chacun regarde
son écran donc en fait chacun peut
regarder ce qu'il a envie là où au
cinéma on va tous et ce que j'aime
beaucoup c'est qu'on est tous réunis
autour du même écran et les niches
n'existent pas vraiment que un film de
genre américain de toute façon il va se
vendre en DVD dans le monde entier un
film français bah il a peu de chance de
se vendre dans le monde entier donc ça
marche vraiment en France si ça marche
pas en France c'est pour ça que moi
j'avais fait tout de suite en anglais
donc ça m'a permis de TR de
international mais ça marche pas en
France et en langue français française
ça marchera nulle part alors qu'un film
américain un film anglais de par la
langue de par la culture bah on le
retrouve en DVD partout il est vendu
partout donc économiquement les gens se
sortent mieux en fait le prochain projet
sur lequel tu travailles c'est à nouveau
une série qui s'appelle Infinity donc
Infinity c'est ça mélange deux genres ça
mélange le thriller et le film de
science-fiction parce que on part donc
d'un crime au Kazakhstan et on va
essayer donc d'enquêter ce qui va nous
emmener dans les ISS c'est jusque dans
l'espace tu as parlé beaucoup de de
compte appppelle sous forme de commande
et cetera mais là Infinity c'est pas la
même chose c'est vraiment un projet sur
lequel tu étais enfin ça a pas la même
place pour toi non parce que c'est un
projet que j'ai initié avec les les les
les enfin initi c'est les scénaristes
qui sont arriv c'est les scénaristes
avec je travaillais qui n'avaient rien à
voir il y a pas de production à l'époque
il y avait rien du tout c'est des
scénarist a j'ai j'ai rencontré via mon
agent on est de la même agence c'est un
projet qu'ils avaient qui se passait
même pas en cas accent qui se passéit en
Guyane avec un projet qui dormait c'est
vraiment il y avait les les prémisses en
fait du projet moi j'ai adoré on s'est
dit B c'est infaisable c'est trop
compliqué moi c'était vraiment le projet
que j'avais envie de faire projet
j'avais envie de faire ça parlait ça
enfin c'est à la fois sérieux je suis
très du polar j'aimis beaucoup
interstell j'aimis beaucoup du PO des
films un peu complexes j'aima beaucoup
le le polar et la science-fiction qui
sont vraiment les trucs que je préfère
mais j'ais passé beaucoup de temps à
faire des comédies à faire des films
d'horreur que je Renis pas du tout hein
que j'adore euh et là c'est c'est
vraiment quelque chose de lequelle je
j'avais envie de de travailler en fait
donc je l'ai porté un peu longtemps on
l'a reécrit entièrement c'était à
l'origine ça d'être un film infaisable
en France et on a fini par faire une
miniérie que voilà qui on a qu'on a
vendu à Canal plus ça mis du temps he
parce qu'il y avait des des projets ang
avait un projet anglais qui était
similaire à l'époque on s'est battu
c'était le premier qui allait arriver
finalement on a réécrit l' le deuxème
épisode et on a réussi à voilà à faire
le le faire en fait parce que c'est
toujours même si on est un peu plus
connu comme ça c'est toujours c'est
toujours un combat de jusqu'au bout tout
le temps et du coup celui-là on a réussi
à le vendre donc j'en suis bah j'en suis
fier parce que c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui me parle voilà c'est un projet
que j'ai porté jusqu'au bout on a été le
faire en Ukraine et au Kazakhstan
j'avais envie de faire en langue kazak
avec des acteurs casazacs m j'aic des
Français mtenc des anglais c'est un peu
la voie sur lesquell je je travaille en
ce moment c'est c'est vraiment la suite
d'
d'Infinity qui a marché plutôt bien à
Canal Plus qui marche bien à
l'international encore une fois plus à
l'international qu'en France ça bien
marché en France mais les gens trouvai
ça un petit peu complexe le public
est-ce que je peux comprendre il y avait
à la fin de de la de la il manque un
épisode en fait qu'on a dû couper voilà
il y a un épisode qui explique un peu
les choses qui a
disparu et du coup c'est ça marche
beaucoup plus à l'international voilà on
va W le mois prochain voilà c'est
quelque chose qui je sais que ça cétait
beaucoup plus payant Mo l'international
qu'en France mais les Français enfin
Canal Plus est très fier et très content
mais ou parce que tu tu l'as dit
rapidement mais vous êtes nommé au Emy a
quand même pour la série enfin les h
Award c'est les Oscars de la de la télé
aux États-Unis quand même c'est juste
enfin on peut pas imaginer mieux que ça
euh non non c'est c'est bah c'est arrivé
il y a de de TR semaines donc ça ça je
pars dans 10 jours je vous dirai ce qui
ce qu'il en est euh oui oui non c'était
c'était assez inattendu c'est assez
inattendu mais même pour les diffuseurs
même pour Canal c'est inattendu parce
que ça ça a bien marché mais c'est ça
reste ça reste un petit peu euh ça très
bien marché sur Canal mais ça reste des
choses un peu un peu étranges pour le
public donc ils l'ont mis un peu dans
casé un peu étrange et c'est beaucoup
mieux vu en fait à l'étranger euh voilà
donc c'est un retour je suis assez
content parce que c'est un retour après
ça me fait revenir en France évidemment
mais c'est toujours agréable Infinity
quand même mélange deux genres c'est à
la fois un thriller et c'est un film de
science-fiction en fait c'était vraiment
la base moi je je suis très fan de
science-fiction j'ai commencé par par
Star Wars et tout j'ai arrivé longtemps
après ou mais après et plein d'autes euh
mais c'est pareil la sciencefixtion en
France très du enfin impossible à à à
gérer à l'inverse le polar parce que les
que j'avais appris ça en faisant faisant
surtout zone blanche qui ni plus moins
qu'un petit film poli ENF un petit film
ça reste des films policiers assez drôle
ça ça marche très bien c'est que les
gens s' habitués à avoir de la alors le
film policier en France ça marche
toujours très bien ça ser un genre on
pourra le faire jusqu'à la fin de notre
vie ça marche très bien euh après je me
dis bah on va rentrer par le polar pour
aller vers la la science-fiction c'est
que au début c'était beaucoup plus SF
c'est ça que j'ai apporté en fait avec
les auteurs je dis mainant on va rentrer
par le polar un po soit au Kazakhstan un
peu j'aime beaucoup les films
hongkongais moi je suis très polar aussi
hongkongais donc j'allais par par ce
biais en fait par le polar on allait
amener les gens tout doucement à arriver
dans l'espace à accepter la
science-fiction je n sais pas pourquoi
on se voit pas alors qu'on était
notamment pour l'espace c'est qu'on
avait des encore Thomas Pesquet j'ai
j'ai contacté aussi beaucoup de gens qui
avaient été pour ce film c'était fort
intéressant claudier nuré tous ces gens
qui sont montés dans l'ISS qu'on fait
l'espace ça reste européen et ça reste
ancré en Europe en fait c'est les les
tirs de de de de combat de l'ISS en fait
ça tirait de à l'époque de Baikonour qui
n'existe plus à cause de la guerre
Ukraine et et Russie mais c'est ça reste
un univers très européen en fait mais
qui a jamais été exploité c'est quelque
chose alors que nous on a enfin dans la
conquête de l'espace on a notres mots à
dire on a de grands cosmonautes qui sont
montés qui sontedescendus et c'est vrai
qu'on utilise peu j'ai on a dû se battre
ça intéressé ça intéressé les les les
les distributeurs bien c'est un sujet
qui reste européen mais de
sciencefiction on peut quand même le
faire sans aller singer un film
américain en fait qui un singer où
prendre al le leur culture par que ça
restait de notre culture en fait mais
mais dur quand même à faire on va parler
de ta dernière production qui est
d'ailleurs on te débauche parce que tu
es en pleine en plein montage et donc
merci de te libérer pour être avec nous
c'est-à-dire que là tu es au commande
d'une nouvelle série pour Canal Plus qui
s'appelle les sentinelles c'est tiré
d'une bande dessinée qui a failli être
adapté il y a quelques temps déjà par
Alexandre qui est un Français expatrié à
Hollywood avec avec un autre réalisateur
français qui s'appelle Julien Mokrani
donc voilà pour X raison le projet ne
s'est pas fait et donc là il est
développé en minisérie et donc tu le
réalise est-ce que tu peux nous
présenter ce projet qui reste quand même
assez secret il y a pas beaucoup
d'information euh pour le moment sur sur
cette série bah pour cause he ça va
sortir que ça ne sortira que en
septembre
2024 je suis en train de finir les les
les deux trois premiers épisodes en fait
en ce moment ben c'est c'est une série
qui a été redéveloppée en fait par un un
scénario qui s'appelle Guillaume
lementand qui a archeté les droits de la
BD ils sont un petit peu éloigné et ils
l'ont vendu après en série pour Canal
Plus canal plus cherche des en ce moment
cherchait pour à se développer dans ils
veulent plus de la série un peu
d'aventure un peu plus j'a aventure
quand je dirais populaire dans le bon
sens et le mauvais sens du terme c'est
un truc beaucoup plus accessible ludique
voilà de une action un peu fantastique
et voilà ce qu'il recherchaient donc ils
ont réussi à vendre ce projet là c'est
vraiment pour le coup ça fait partie
c'est comme à l'époque quand j'ai fait
zone blanche c'est vraiment des
commandes moi entre mes deux projets
tant que je développe c'est toujours
très long j'accepte de temps en temps
bah de rentrer dans l'univers d'autres
gens là ils m'ont laissé euh je
connaissais évidemment la BD là ils
m'ont laissé j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur
la direction artistique aussi ce qui
d'où je viens moi ça m'intéressait aussi
euh donc j'ai ils m'ont laissé faire une
adaptation artistique de toute la série
donc avec les les budgets et la
préparation qui était très bien et c'est
un c'est une série ça sera assez éloigné
de la BD pour cause que la BD raconte
beaucoup ça la BD revient sur les grands
au moment de la guerre 1418 les grandes
batailles revu et corrigé à travers ces
personnages qui sont les sentinelles qui
sont des
personnages blindés mais qui sont qui
restent des humains euh nous il y a un
côté un peu le enfin l'auteur nous
l'auteur a a été beaucoup plus du côté
fantastique ça se passe dans Paris aussi
ça se passe pas que sur les champs de
bataille pour des causes aussi purement
économique en fait il y a des choses
qu'on pouvait pas tout montrer ça
restera spectaculaire mais un niveau on
reste quand même en enfin c'est des
budgets français franco-français donc en
fait on des budgets un peu plus limités
euh mais on arrive à développer quand
même ça ça se passe entre le Paris les
basfonds de Paris je peux pas tout vous
dire mais il y a un côté par rapport à
la BD il y a il y a il y a un aspect
fantastique gothique totalement assumé
avec des pouvoir comme ça dans dans
voilà ça va assez loin dans dans la
proposition euh après j'espère que ça
plaira ou ça on va voir on sait jamais
en fait au début quand ça quand ça ça ça
part comme ça et là je suis en train de
finir on on partage en fait je partage
le la la réalisation avec Édouard Salier
qui est un autre réalisateur qui a sorti
son longmétrage aussi qui vient aussi du
film fant enfin du fantastique aussi
voilà on verra si ça marche très bien
merci Thierry merci on on va se tourner
maintenant vers la salle vous proposer
le micro si vous avez des questions à
poser à notre invité tout le long de de
cette masterclass vous avez évoqué le
fait que il y a des difficultés en
France à raconter certains certaines
histoires certains univers est-ce
que ça a évolué est-ce que ça évolue
est-ce qu'il y a un peu un peu d'espoir
quoi mais il y a toujours de l'espoir au
non tois les séries enfin jeis pas si
vous imaginez vous avez beaucoup de
plateformes mais ça sort tous les jours
donc en fait pour intéresser les gens
faut vraiment se creuser la tête mais ça
c'est le bon côté en fait je pense qu'
croyait que ça allait étouffer le cinéma
mais au contraire ça donne ça obligé les
gens de de s'amuser beaucoup plus et de
chercher de chercher de chercher et
d'étonner surtout et pas faire les
choses qui ont dit ah ça ça va marcher
souvent ce qui marche d'ailleurs ils
sont toujours surpris tous les succès de
Netflix ou les autres c'est on s'y
attendait pas ils s'y attendent jamais
tuis ça ça revient je donne un exemple
de euh moi je suis sur un thriller tu
vois polar super noir on dit mais ça
marche plus le poilard noir là il y a
Netflix il sort body j'ai pas encore vu
la série hein mais et ça fait de
semaines que j'entends plus parler que
de ça ça dans le milieu du cinéma des
gens d ah là là mais vous avez pas des
trilur un peu noir tout comme ça parce
que ça redémarre à chaque fois on sait
jamais en fait donc faut jamais
abandonné ça tourne en fait ça tourne le
goût tourne et revient revient les
séries c'est a pour ça de les
plateformes un côté sa pour le cinéma
c'est que ça ça remet un peu de vif de
peps voilà c'est mon avis en fait vous
avez évoqué une carrière aux États-Unis
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
et vous avez aussi dit que vous préférez
travailler en France et pourquoi alors
en fait aux États-Unis j'étais j'ai fait
des années quand j'ai commencé la
publicité avec mon frère après ça a
beaucoup mieux marché en fait j'aiété
aux États-Unis j'étais représenté en
France et à Los Angeles à New York en
publicité j'ai fait beaucoup beaucoup de
publicité là-bas euh à Los Angeles à New
York notamment euh là j'ai rencontré
plein de gens très connus qui m'ont aidé
j'avais été à l'époque sur le plateau de
David finisher quand il faisait panroom
Tim Burton avait on est vraiment c'est
assez facile en fait qu'and AR qu'on est
jeune souvent c'est la Hollywood et le
bon côté dehollywood c'est qu'ils sont
très frayant des jeunes talents donc
alors qu'on arrive ils te prennent tout
de suite à bras le corp donc tu vois
beaucoup de gens tout de suite on un
agent on te présente plein de gens euh
j'ai fait la pub ça a très bien marché
j'en ai fait beaucoup là-bas après laiss
c'est un long métrage j'ai commencé à à
travailler sur un longmétrage avec une
une scénariste qui s'appelit Caroline
Thomson qui était la scénariste de Tim
Burton qui a fait mrter Jack qui a fait
de Romain d'argent qui avait écrit un un
film très étrange sur le Frix je sais
pas si vous connaissez le vieux film qui
s'appelle Frix qui une adaptation en
fait c'était une biographie de Johnny
Eck sur lequel j'ai travaillé pendant 1
an ce qui était tourné on a fait des
essais avec James Franco enfin l'acteur
qu'on a vu dans euh voilà mais c'était
un film qui était très noir sur un sur
ça parlait vraiment des frics et des
handicapés qui étaaient tourné en parti
noir et blanc quiit un film fantastique
mais ça m'a pris un an pour arriver en
fait à à pas grand-chose souvent comme
ça arrive en fait c'est très dur de
perer en fait à Los Angeles faut
vraiment soyez habité à a à JAAC qui
vraiment s installé mais lui il produit
vraiment des choses comme il a toujours
rêvé de faire des films d'horreur comme
les américains il le fait là-bas avec
beaucoup d'amour et là où moi j'avais
j'aimais bien un peu transgressif donc
j'aimais bien de faire des film un peu
étrange euh là-bas ça marchait pas très
bien donc au bout d'un an enfin pour
ceux qui verront qui vont hly est génial
hein mais fautit pas y passer trop de
temps en fait ça se bouffe un peu on a
peu de liberté en réalisateur on reste
quand même qu'un technicien mais
vraiment on te met vraiment au milieu
d'un le côté heuteurisme raconter des
histoires tout monde s'en fout c'est
vraiment un technicien point bas faire
de la pub là-bas c'est très drôle he
parce qu'on a accès évidemment à tout
Los Angeles les gens les les techniciens
qui ont travaillé sur tous les gros
films donc ça c'est toujours c'est comme
un petit rêve d'enfant mais j'avoue que
moi j'ai atteint mon rêve d'enfant puis
je me suis dit bah en fait non je
préférais l'Europe enfin l'idéal en fait
j'aime beaucoup par contre dans aux
États-Unis c'est évidemment ils ont un
bon il y enfin moi j'en rêvais que je
suis arrivé je viens plutôt de ce cinéma
là donc c'était plutô avoir accès aux
acteurs au décor donc moi mon mon idéal
c'est c'est c'est c'est des financements
européens d'un film tourné au Canada
avec des Anglais enfin ça serait le
paradis mais dans le studio lui-même
Hollywood et voilà ça c'est pas j été un
petit peu beaucoup c'était pas pas très
agréable en fait alors bonjour Est-ce
que dans votre carrière votre expérience
en tant que réalisateur de pub vous a
est-ce que vous sentez que votre
expérience en tant que réalisateur de
pub vous a influencé un peu négativement
dans votre carrière de réalisateur comme
par exemple pour atomic Circus ù vous
avez un peu subi les stigmat qu'on peut
avoir sur les mur en scènes de pub oui
j'ai pas de regret d'avoir fait parce
que c'est c'est ma carrière chacun fait
son chemin mais c'est vrai qu'and moi je
fais de la pub à enfin quand je dis au
niveau j'ai fait beaucoup de pub et j'en
continue un petit
peu c'est pas l'estigma de de faire de
visuel ça t'apprend fait la pub ça
t'apprend pas vraiment ça t'apprend
techniquement à faire des des petites
histoires ça m'aappris vraiment j'ai
appris vraiment mon métier en faisant la
publicité la seule chose qu'on t'apprend
pas en publicité c'est ce que tu as
envie de raconter ce que je disais il y
a pas c'est que tu fais juste des
petites histoires un peu débiles avec
des petits concepts et ce qui manque du
coup après on te lance dans le cinéma
c'est vrai que j'avais un on avait un et
moi on avait un savoirfaire de de faire
des images faire des scènes d'action
faire des des jolies scènes donc ce
savoirfaire était super donc nous on se
lançait dans les histoires en disant bon
bah voilà on va raconter scénario et on
s'était rarement penché à le et c'était
un peu bête sur le sur l'histoire qu'on
avait vraiment envie de raconter c'est
que le milieu de la publicité à tendance
à te fagociter on prend juste un c'est
c'est c'est une coquille c'est vraiment
du visuel du visuel du genre du visuel
du genre du visuel donc en fait tu tu tu
peux te faire aspirer là-dedans et ça
marche très bien alors après on a aussi
c'est très financièrement c'est très
bien payé on visite partout donc le
milieu de la pub est très brillant c'est
mais quand on se penche après sur le
cinéma qu'on vient et que tu viens de
sur un plateau avec des acteurs et tuas
les gens qui demande ce qu' on envie de
raconter c'est ça qui te manque c'est
dit ah il faut vraiment te pencher sur
ce que tu as vraiment envie de raconter
et j'avoue que les années de pub mont
juste un peu endormi de ce côtélà c'est
que j'ai oublié de penser à ce que
j'avais vraiment envie de raconter et
c'est que maintenant to vois jeeveux
gris un peu tardivement que je me dis ah
il y a des choses que j'ai envie de
raconter des histoires des choses qui
qui qui que j'avais depuis avantin mais
qui sont venus petit à petit en fait et
ça la pub a tendance un petit peu à te
t'écarter de ton chemin mais ça reste
aussi très
intéressant bonjour bonjour euh en tant
que réalisateur est-ce que vous avez un
point ou un côté de la réalisation que
vous appréciez particul particulièrement
pardon ou détester forcment moi
personnellement que je discute avec
beaucoup d'amis réalisateurs qui aiment
pas trop soit le plateau soit moi c'est
vrai que je suis pour le coup un vrai
amoureux du cinéma et j'aime beaucoup
toutes les c'est tellement différent euh
alors c'est un peu bateau ce que je ve
dire mais j'aime vraiment toutes les
périodes du cinéma de la préparation
parce que tout est possible c'est Ren
avoir on est là on rêve d'un truc tout
on fait des dessins on est dans la
création tout est possible après j'irais
le moins le plus chiant c'est les
repérage c'est c'est du minibus pendant
des heures des heures des heures des
heures à changer voilà ça c'est le truc
le plus chiant du monde faut savoir que
c'est avant le tournage tu fais tu
tourne dans un minibus pendant 6 mois
voilà pendant manger des vieux sandwich
c'est le cinéma et tu es épuisé quand tu
commences souvent quand tu commences le
tournage ailleurs tu es épuisé tuas
Besin d'avir fait ton film 30 fois et tu
es crevé après tu as le plateau qui est
carrément aussi une autre c'est
tellement différ différent en fait et
c'est ça que j'aime moi personnellement
dans le cinéma c'est que ça partage
vraiment des choses très différentes le
tournage estant quelque chose de très
instinctif assez épuisant et très
sportif que que je contrôle enfin que
j'aimais beaucoup j'ai fait beaucoup de
pub donc j'aimais beaucoup le tournage
même techniquement je me sens à l'aise
avec les caméra et la postp c'est
vraiment le le moment où on rassemble
tout que j'aime aussi beaucoup parce que
là on est installé et on fait on fait
vivre les choses j'aime beaucoup la
musique j'aime beaucoup le mix à la fin
parce qu'on peut retravailler y compris
quand on fait des films un peu de genre
ou des choses comme ça c'est le son a
une importance énorme moi je suis très
fan de musique de film c'est quel chose
que j'aime beaucoup j'aime beaucoup les
enregistrements de musique toutes les
parties en fait de du cinéma sont quand
même assez passionnantes il y en a plus
longues que d'autres la vente aussi la
vente au début est un peu compliquée
c'est pas la partie la plus intéressante
mais mais très nécessaire est-ce
qu'avoir une idée de l'esthétisme avant
le propos
ou le fond d'un film est une mauvaise
chose comment all est les deux St
dénaturer le projet c'est une bonne
question moi j'avoue que j'ai je l'ai
fait dans ce sens là j'avoue que
maintenant j'ai perd ça m'a perdu un
petit peu de temps mais parce que j'ai
mis souvent l'esthétisme au cœur du
projet avant de commencer le le le fond
euh j'ai vu que des fois ça marchait
bien les notre premier courmétrage était
c'était à la fois très esthétique mais
ça parlait de ça ça parlait d'un milieu
de l'expressionniste allemand donc
c'était très au milieu de ça donc on a
trouvé un propos qui racontait
l'histoire de quelqu'un qui fabriquait
des marionnettes donc le propos et le G
l'esthétisme était lié par moment bah je
me suis on s'est laissé aller un petit
peu plus à un esthétisme qu'on vient de
la BD des ches comme ça a un peu plus
visuel c'est qu'on était aussi intéressé
par les les costumes les décors la
lumière l'ambiance en fait je sais que
je un résateur j'aime beaucoup les créer
des ambiances j'avoue que maintenant
avec un peu de regret je je me serais un
peu plus intéressé à à la fabrication de
l'histoire au scénario
euh l'un tu peux vraiment faire il y a
beaucoup de rateurs que j'aime beaucoup
il sont très esthétiques je pense qu'ils
font l'un avec l'autre je par de West
Anderson qui est vraiment le lui il fait
tout tous ses storyboards c'est animé et
il fait ses propres voix faut savoir que
West Anderson fait tout tout son film
est en storyboard animé tout tout tout m
qu les acteurs et c'est lui qui mime
toutes ses propres voix il fait toutes
ses petites voix comme ça t ses
dialogues tout c'est vraiment des films
d'animation qui fait après en réaliste
alors après ça être un petit peu sur un
plateau ça devient un petit peu chant
qu'on refait exactement la même chose
mais lui il part vraiment il y a des
gens qui parlent vraiment de ça après il
a trouvé son propos et son histoire je
pense ça dépend qu'on arrive à il faut
faut quand même que ça soit lié c'est
que ce qui moi les erreurs que j'ai fait
par le passé c'est de de mettre
l'esthétisme avant le je dirais le fond
sans avoir une idée de de comment je
pouvais mêler les deux très bien merci
Thierry on est à à la fin de cette
Masterc on tient aussi le temps j'ai
quand même moi une dernière remarque à
faire c'est je t'ai entendu depuis le
début et particulièrement en répondant
aux questions des étudiants un mot qui
revient très souvent c'est j'ai appris
j'ai appris j'ai appris après ton
premier court-métrage effectivement euh
mais ensuite dans le monde de la
publicité après ton prier premier
longmétrage dans les séries et là tu
viens de le de le redire est-ce que
c'est un un mot clé peut-être alors
confier on te parlait de de conseils à
leur donner est-ce que c'est quelque
chose qui est finalement une carrière
c'est un apprentissage permanent
peut-être bah oui je pense que enfin moi
j'apprends tous les jours tout le
temps en faisant de parler aussi quand
je parlais de jeunes génération c'est
pas je parler de ma fille qui école de
cinéma aussi le ça te repousse ailleurs
c'est que cette jeunesse et tes envies
les choses que tu vois ça repousse
ailleurs mais je pense que c'est pareil
si tu suis les que enfin je me compare
pas un grand réalisateur mais tous les
réalisateurs que que j'admire ils
changent ils change beaucoup tu vois bon
très j'étais très plus jeune très
speedberg comme ça donc mais ils ont
changé ils sont passé des découpages
très si vous analysez bien vraiment les
découpage de ces réalisateurs en terme
de film ils sont passé des fois des
trucs très statiques d'un coup ils ont
découvert un chef sont faire des caméras
porté faire des longs plans séquen
qu'ils évolue beaucoup leur sujet évolue
la façon de filmer évolue je pense qu'on
perfectionne quelque chose mais on
évolue à à chaque fois et je pense que
ce qui est passionnant et surtout qu'on
vit dans une époque qui évolue aussi
donc moi ça ça vient plus de mes études
des beauxards c'est faut vraiment être
aux agaguet de tout ce qui se passe et
puis d'apprendre tout le temps en fait
moi c'est plus la ENF le cinéma ce que
j'aime c'est un travail de groupe aussi
donc c'est découvrir des gens et puis
les gens il s rebondit différemment et
d'apprendre oui on apprend j'y suis
encore j'apprends beaucoup beaucoup tous
les jours tout le
temps très bien merci beaucoup Thierry
on peut t'applaudir bien fort merci
on
peut on peut
également applaudir on peut aussi
également applaudir ton frère Didier
parce qu'on a beaucoup parlé de son
travail aussi aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
parce que tu as beaucoup de travail avec
la post-production des sentinelles on te
souhaite le meilleur pour la suite et
pour les EMI tout particulièrement merci
à vous merci à toute l'équipe des
étudiants en coulisse Margot Jonas leurs
équipes merci à Enzo pour l'habillage et
on se retrouve le mois prochain pour une
nouvelle masterclass au revoir merci au
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
revoir